completely impervious to uh hypocrisy  take a look at this what what message  would you have for women who are  considering having an abortion when uh  when a woman becomes pregnant there's  two bodies there  it's not one and it's not my body my  choice oh it's care for  care for the child there's adoption  there's  there's other routes to go  you know what do you what do you say to  people out there that that um say that  they don't want to get the covered  vaccine  um  if the my body my choice works for  abortion why doesn't the same work for  the vaccine which of course you could  say the same thing right if wait hold on  a second if my body my choice works for  the vaccine why couldn't it work for  abortion like without a hint of irony  if it's my body it should be my choice  of whether or not i want to vaccinate